en quelques heures de 170 millions
d'arbres ont été arrachés par les vents
violents qui ont donc déferlé sur la
france deux jours d'affilée
le parc du château de versailles a été
très sévèrement atteint un grand
chantier de restauration du parc était
déjà en cours avant les destructions il
a été renforcé et bientôt certaines
parties des jardins reprendront la forme
qu'elle avait autant de marie-antoinette
reportage mari de l'artière stéphane
taponier le temple de l'amour où
marie-antoinette aimait venir se reposer
à l'abri du soleil a échappé à la
terrible tempête un miracle les arbres
ne soit tombé qu'à quelques centimètres
et heureusement l'on épargne et des
chaînes d être des mélèzes deux fois
centenaires aujourd'hui nettoyer le parc
du trianon est très clairsemé les
replantations se feront en janvier mais
pas à l'identique les études historiques
vont permettre de reconstituer le parc
créé par marie antoinette
ici le jardin anglais retrouvera son
tracé d'origine avec davy burnes sommes
début idées ou des lilas la tempête en
nous permettant d'accélérer la
replantation va nous permettre de
représenter le par tel que la reine le
connaissait à titre indicatif un champ
de céréales qui avait disparu depuis le
xviiie siècle va être remis en place et
les visiteurs dans quelques années
re découvriront les fenêtres des
fenêtres du petit trianon le hameau de
la reine à travers un champ de blé
exactement comme le voyait marionnettes
et au pied du belvédère on replantera
une vigne secteur par secteur le parc va
renaître grâce aux amoureux de
versailles qui dans le monde entier ont
répondu à la souscription lancée au
lendemain de la tempête
en adoptant un arbre chaque donateur
participe au reboisement
aujourd'hui le chiffre des dix mille
arbres est presque atteint mais il faut
implanter beaucoup plus pour être sûr
qu'ils vivent
on va donner une carte avec la croix
coup il y aura eu à l'arbre mais il ya
encore de la place pour pour un lance
pour adopter des armes et nous ferons
une grande fête le 9 juin nadja fixer la
date même de juin 2001 pour remercier
tous ceux qui rompent l'un d'eux
alors invité tout le monde il faudra
trois ans pour réaménager la totalité du
parc un ambitieux programme de 140
millions de francs pour que le domaine
du roi soleil
retrouvant sa splendeur